going back to cut so
cuss had also done it in the past before
right like a custom knew how to develop
people right he had a reputation for
developing people did you ever see
anybody that he worked with that they
just couldn't take it and they quit
working with cuss like some people just
emotionally couldn't handle that kind of
pressure no cuss knows when to put the
gas on when put the brakes on you know
that's what a teacher does he's a
teacher we all
teach everyone all of us teach everyone
all teachers and students this world is
one big school and we're the students of
this world so he knew timing and he knew
uh when when to motivate and what not to
motivate absolutely
he knows the mind is always hungry the
mind wants to do good
but we get so many
negative thoughts in our minds almost
overwhelming to be positive so mike you
have to know this is so important
because you're like an encyclopedia in
this area because you work with the best
and you become the best so i'm trying to
extract as much information from you as
possible in this so would you say for
him when you were cocky he humbled you
when you were down he built you up would
you say it was like a timing thing with
them
no it was no game you know um there's so
much power and humbleness
you know when i'm when i'm promoting the
fight i say outrageous things and stuff
but i know the power of humbleness now
how did you learn that i have to lose
everything
got it
got it well now you gotta get a lot of
it back by the way you got some i mean
you know you don't want people know you
got money means nothing
once you listen
if you think a lot of money will make
you happy
you never had a lot of money before
so what do you value now what's at the
top for you to value me
my children my whole
barometer of life
listen
listen i've been down and up down and up
broken up and why am i still here
talking to these guys why you guys
paying me to talk to y'all
why did we do it guys i've been in
prison a bunch of times i don't
i don't kick some people's ass on
television and call people white [ __ ]
hunky and listen um
and the reason i'm still here is because
i understand what humbleness is you know
i understand humbleness and um
i think sometimes god doesn't like me
because he knows i can't handle this
[ __ ]
i'm serious he knows i can't handle this
[ __ ]
no i got a label on me i'm the best
fighter i gotta i have to i i'm um i
have to conduct myself in a certain way
that's what my wife tells me now she
tells you that you have to conduct with
something a certain way
what do you think about that yeah you
have multiple matters you can't go to
the club no more oh yeah that's what you
know they want to control your life
they want to control your life how do
you handle that like you can't go to the
club i mean that's just too many
restrictions i don't go to the class you
don't go to the club is it weighing it
out saying club's wife what's more
important it's just
i i can go to the club i just don't want
to come back and see you after i went to
the club
you know you know when they look at you
and this and you want to say what the
what did i do i just went out and listen
listen
my wife don't think i know she put she
put a tracker on my knees she got me a
new truck and have a tracker on it right
now
my right hand my wife do you know that
or you don't know that oh i know now
[Applause]
why does she do that with a track on the
car
so what do you do are you strategic you
go park it somewhere call an uber and go
to your
club or no i don't need driving when
she's in it
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]